i just believe it
there's nothing to
it
i believe i can fly
in a perfect world no one outruns or
flies away from accountability not even
the pop singer r kelly who on wednesday
was sentenced to 30 years in federal
prison on charges he moved underage
girls across state lines for sex
kelly's victims say they never thought
they'd see the day
i was an up-and-coming singer i was
a girl full of life
very innocent but very driven
and
preyed upon basically at the mall in
aventura florida
and promised
just a mentorship and quickly turned
into
i would just say a sex slave kelly had
been accused for more than 30 years of
preying on teenagers using their dreams
of stardom to physically sexually and
mentally abuse them he illegally married
the singer aaliyah in 1994 when she was
15 years old the marriage was annulled
kelley's 2002 trial on child pornography
charges ended six years later with an
acquittal
but in 2017 prosecutors started taking
women's accusations more seriously
thanks in part to the documentary
surviving r
kelly can you describe the physical
abuse
god i can't take another day i can't do
this anymore in 2019 kelly was arrested
in the current case his defense team
says it's appeal
all i can tell you is there was no
enterprise there was no enterprise it
was one man with allegations by a number
of women which doesn't make it an
enterprise and that is why he's not
guilty of of racketeering kelly's
victims say they're counting on the
courts to make things right
i started this journey 30 years ago i
was 14 years old when i encountered
robert sylvester kelly
there wasn't a day in my life
up until this moment that i actually
believe that the judicial system will
come through for black and brown girls
i stand here very proud
of my judicial system
very proud of my fellow survivors
and very pleased with the outcome r
kelly's legal problems are far from over
in august he will go on trial in
illinois on similar charges
rosalyn jordan al jazeera